One of the best things about being here at Comic-Con--
(shrieking)
Andy, look out!
Look out, Andy!
(shrieking)
Oh, what, you mean this zombie?
[Conan] Yes, look out!
Oh, come on, Conan.
I mean, zombies get hungry just like everyone else.
And you know what they say.
You're not you when you're hungry.
(laughing)
Here, I'll take care of it.
(growling)
Here you go, buddy.
No, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Take a little bit there.
That's all you need.
(laughing)
Thank you, Andrew.
Oh, you're welcome.
(laughing)
(cheering)
(applauding)
Here.
Conan!
Are you enjoying your week at Comic-Con?
Yes, yes, I really am.
Thanks for asking, yes.
Splendid.
And who's on the show this evening?
Oh, we have the cast of LEGO Ninjago Movie.
We have Kumail Nanjani, Olivia Munn.
We have Justin Theroux.
Well, I suppose a bit of Justin Theroux's brain
wouldn't be so bad.
(laughing)
Would you kindly point me in the direction
of your green room?
Oh, yeah, sure, no problem.
take the stairs down, first door on your left,
and then you can't miss it.
Justin should be in there.
Got it, thank you, old chap, Andrew.
Have a marvelous week!
(elegant classical music)
What a lovely fellow!
[Andy] See?